Today
in India more than 75%
are non-Muslims.
75%.
If we Muslims wanted at that time we
could have forced every non-Muslim to
accept Islam at the point of the sword.
We didn't do it. If we had done that
there wouldn't have been more than 75%
non-Muslims.
These 75% non-Muslims of India they are
giving shahada. They are bearing witness
that Islam was not sped by the sword.
At that time when we ruled India for a
thousand years the Muslims if they
wanted they could have forced every
non-Muslim to accept Islam but they
didn't do it because Islam does not give
permission. Islam says there's no
compulsion in religion stands out clear
from error.
So these more than 75% non-Muslims of
India today are giving shahada. They are
bearing witness that Islam wasn't spread
by the sword.
Which Muslim army went to Indonesia
today?
According to statistics, Indonesia has
the maximum number of Muslims in one
country according to India.
About 29
million Muslims in Indonesia
or 239
or 240 million. In India the government
says 215 million 14.3% according to me
it's much more more than 280 million
more than 20% are Muslims
but even if you agree so Indonesia which
is theoretically supposed to be the
country which has maximum number of
Muslims in the world I'm asking you a
question which Muslim army went to
Indonesia which Muslim army went to
Malaysia which Muslim army went to the
east coast of Africa which sword
The businessmen went there to do
business.
When they did business, they preached
the religion and people accepted Islam.
Which army went to Indonesia? Which army
went to Malaysia? Which army went to
Gambia? Which army went to the east
coast of Africa to Sineagal?
Later on the Britishers come
and they play games.
So these countries are giving shahada
that Islam was not sped by the sword.
Which sword? Thomas Khalai he writes in
his book heroes and hero worship that
you should first get your sword. Every
new idea initially begins in the mind of
one in one man in the full world alone.
And if one man alone propagates and
picks up the sword, it will be no
benefit. First you have to get the
sword. Which sword is thal talking
about? He's talking about the sword of
the intellect.
I started my talk by quoting vers of the
Quran of surah chapter number 16 verse
14. says,
"Invite all to the way of the lord with
wisdom and we preaching and argue with
them and reason with them in the ways
that are best most gracious." It's the
sword of the intellect.
It's not the sword of steel. Even if we
had the sword of steel, we could not use
it.
Allah says in surah bakar 2 verse 256
like there's no compulsion in religion
stands out clear from error anyone who
holds and grasps the hand of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala he will take you
from darkness to light
it is no compulsion religion it is a
sword of intellect sword of hikma
and today
we find that the fastest growing
religion in the world today in America
it's is Islam. The fastest growing
religion in Europe is Islam.
And if you read
the reader digest
alman year book
of 1984
and this article was repeated in the
plain truth magazine. It gave the
increase in the major world religion in
a span of 50 years from 1934 to 1984.
And the radical said the maximum
increase
in religion in this 50 years was Islam
235%.
Christianity
only 47%.
I'm asking you the question which war
took place in the in these 50 years from
1934 to 1984 which converted or
increased the number of Muslims all over
the world. Which war 235%
Islam only 47%. That means five times
more.
Five times
multiply by 5 is 235. ISLAM SPREAD FIVE
TIMES MORE THAN CHRISTIANITY IN the 50
years. Which war took place in this 50
years which forced non-Muslims to become
Muslims?